drew
i'm drew now adults who change their
first names for no reason
there are valid reasons to go through
name changes but just because i like how
it sounds isn't one of them lisa
sorry lavendocious you can call me drew
no i'm not going to call you that cool
i can't control what you do i can only
control what i do
and jim should change his name to
richard because that was completely a
dick move
look you can love jimmy boy all you want
but under the surface halpert is a
complete [ __ ] and you all know it
yes i have decided to shun andy bernard
for the next three years
thinking that being shunned by dwight is
a punishment tell him
bears can climb faster than they can run
false bears can climb fast but they can
run faster
this fact doesn't even make sense on a
logical level and dwight should not be
the type of character to get this stuff
wrong
man i thought your name was put yvonne
rodriguez shaming
these are very dangerous machines down
here and the upstairs workers
michael should not go anywhere near them
i haven't seen this much upstairs
downstairs drama since i benched the
entirety of downton abbey last week
for the third time why matthew why
i mean need a minute like sometimes
computers can explode
can they not no no
unless it has a lithium battery so maybe
slow your roll there with the absolutes
flenderson
that's fat butt disease that's what
you're suffering from yeah but disease
inquiring as to the size of your
co-workers posterior and any related
medical conditions they're in without
explicit consent
i'm going to say 50. 51. oh don't be
that
it's a strategy as the arbiter on all
these arguments i'm applying the sin to
the fellas here if you don't want
someone to play the bitter dollar prices
right strategy
then decide the order ahead of time by
random draw or just do anonymous
guessing for such gambling addicts you
sure do seem like a bunch of noobs at
this
i don't know how the whole betting thing
started i'm guessing because the writers
needed a b plot for the safety episode
and one was like hey i recently lost my
home in a bet because i had triple h
over cena at wrestlemania 22. so
what if they gambled and then the others
were like josh get some help man but
also sure let's do gambling
unless you establish a no going under
rule and since oscar was next lowest at
42 10 is not technically out until
27 have been counted so give it a bit
halpert also handling each individual
piece of the complimentary candy
it's really hard to demonstrate
depression their safety training had
visuals
yeah you are
so right gifting michael this kind of
weaponry is really on you pam you've
been working here for over three years
you know better you don't go to the
science museum
and get handed a pamphlet on electricity
you go to the science museum
and you put your hand on a metal ball
but you could also probably get a
pamphlet on electricity
i thought i'd bounce here for a while
relieve some stress and then move on
with my day
not nodding things and let's just say
that i just sent back love actually
which was awesome not the director said
let's have creed take a bite at the
bottom of the apple so people will know
he's an insane [ __ ]
also take apart the trampoline stick it
in the baler you're literally being
recorded at close range by two camera
crews
what are you trying to hide i am ready
to do this
i'm ready to make a point me psyching
myself up before sins narration somehow
makes it into this episode
dwight [ __ ] taking chain curtain's name
in vain
attention workers politics
this is just offensive angela wouldn't
even need to submit a writing sample to
get hired on at tv
sins also we're with angela on this one
as with most office episodes we're going
to give a few cents for insensitivity
but because of how we feel about this
subject
one more reminder if you or anyone else
is thinking about harming yourself help
is available at 1-800-273-8255
the number again is
youtube channel 1-800-273-8255 a cringe
comedy show that is aging poorly
but it's just that important to us
speaking of that cringe comedy show
i brave heart if we got to a scene of
william wallace having his knee broken
by prince edward an ice rink i'm taking
all the sins back
five bucks says it's over 50. you really
want to bet most
gamblers when they go to gamble they go
to win when we go to gamble we go to
lose
that's what we've been trying to tell
you mike it's serious down there
we do dangerous stuff danger i walk on
the wild side
i laugh in the face of danger
you may be asking yourself what am i
doing on a trampoline
well each leap brings us closer to god
catch me lord catch me rock and roll
rock and roll that's right i'm not
thinking rocking